tous les mois il y avait un journal
anonyme qui paraissait ou des rédacteurs
anonymes
elise est une [__] du mois les soirées
les distraire ce donc les filles
arrivent en premier à une soirée
quelques heures après les garçons
arrivent une fois que les filles sont un
peu alcoolisé pour entre guillemets les
cueillir c'était vrai aussi rappelle
marine je suis une ancienne étudiante en
école de commerce
comme beaucoup d'étudiants déjà vécu des
situations de sexisme pendant mes années
d'études
[Musique]
je pense qu'on peut faire on peut parler
très longtemps des traditions sexistes
en école de commerce je parle de
s'excite parce que c'est ce que j'ai
vécu
on peut aussi parler de racisme et
d'homophobie qui sont aussi des
situations présentes
[Musique]
ça paraît complètement irréel en fait
quand on lit ces articles on se dit mais
comment on en est arrivé là
comment on a pu laisser des situations
de telles situations arriver faut savoir
qu'il ya quand même un contexte une
dynamique sociale derrière qui est très
puissante des fêtes groupes de besoins
très voire d'intégration de peur du
rejet
moi par exemple mes premières années
d'études j'ai complètement adhéré au
système
j'ai intégré le sexisme comme norme et
malgré voilà un malaise que je
ressentais j'avais pas du tout les mots
pour identifier ce qui n'allait pas et
en fait je pense que c'est le cas de
beaucoup d'étudiants et d'étudiantes qui
vont se taire qui vont parfois normalisé
des comportements qui sont gravés
problématique et dans le pire des cas
qui vont les reproduire on a 300 à 600
étudiants et étudiantes de sensiblement
même âge pour certains qui ont fait une
école de près par des classes
préparatoires
pendant deux ans très intense qui sont
réunis au même endroit voire qui vivent
au même endroit sur certains campus et
dans un contexte de fête d'alcool de 1
besoin fort d'intégration qui se
matérialise par l'adhésion à des
associations
et ça c'est un contexte à très fort
risque pour les violences sexuelles et
sexistes
[Musique]
malgré mitu malgré la libération de la
parole à ce sujet je voyais que la
situation a changé
peu voire pas du tout en école de
commerce et du coup j'ai monté un projet
qui s'appelle le safe campus qui a un
projet de lutte contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles dans
l'enseignement supérieur et en
particulier en école de commerce
ça fait des années qu'on des
sensibilisations sur l'alcool sur la
drogue
donc c'est quelque chose qui est connu
donc il faut prendre ses responsabilités
prendre ses responsabilités quand une
administration d'école de commerce est
effectivement interdire de telles
pratiques
mais c'est aussi aller plus loin c'est
faire de la prévention positive qui
passe par de la sensibilisation
obligatoire pour les étudiants en
gestion d'écoles de commerce sur les
stéréotypes de genre sur le consentement
qui passe aussi par la formation des
encadrants et des encadrantes comment on
accompagne une victime comment on écoute
une victime
comment on décèle des situations de
violence cela passe notamment par la
mise en place d'un protocole deux
signalements qui est clair qui est
transparent
une victime je sais exactement à qui je
dois m'adresser une référé et comment je
vais être prise en charge il faut que
les administrations elles reconnaissent
ce risque elles reconnaissent cette
responsabilité qu'elle la prenne en
charge et qu'elle fasse une priorité de
la lutte contre les violences sexistes
et sexuelles et ça pour éviter à la fois
de génération d'étudiantes et
d'étudiants potentiellement traumatisée
et à la fois aussi pour éviter d'avoir
des futurs cadres managers qui
reproduisent des comportements
problématiques est grave ce soit dans
les entreprises où d'ailleurs dans leur
vie dans leur vie personnelle
je pense que c'est difficile après de
promouvoir
l'égalité au travail des professionnels
quand en fait pendant les années de
formation
on a potentiellement subi beaucoup de
sexisme subi des violences
la fête les associations c'est important
c'est des temps qui sont des temps fort
dans la vie d'un étudiant et d'une
étudiante qui sont potentiellement
créateur de beaucoup d'opportunités de
rencontres voilà donc il faut que ces
temps là et redeviennent des espaces
qu'ils soient sûrs et bienveillant pour
l'ensemble des étudiants et des
étudiantes
l'idée de ces campus et l'idée et je
pense de mettre en face au dispositif
c'est pas du tout 2
de dire la fête c'est mal la chose s'est
vraiment de dire on va faire en sorte
que ce contexte il faut profite à fond à
tout le monde quoi